your look has improved quite a bit it
does not hurt to look like this is you
on the cover of yeah that's that's more
or less what my torso looks like I can
see that picture with a jheri curl yeah
but I'm just saying that's please tell
me they photoshopped the hell out of
that that's you that's all you right
that's incredible that that was you must
workout to get that body you have to
workout 24 hours a day you mean you're
doing some kind of ab work
right now actually I am I'm contracting
my abs yeah Joe there was a slight
movement there and it was exciting it's
really about diet it's exciting yeah
looks like rabbits are fighting in there
you know it's crazy you play this a
doctor an m.d. on rosewood right and you
do a great job but but people have
noticed that you're shirtless a lot
you're shirtless yes you're a shirtless
doctor yes well now did you know when
you took the job please gentlemen
did you know when you took the job that
they would be asking to take your shirt
off a lot in the role I did not see well
I read the pilot and the pilot the
character in the first scene he was
walking around with his shirt off um so
I did the pilot because by the way our
Creator Todd Hoffman told me to tell you
hello I think you guys going back yeah
we go way way back no but you don't
really know so then so then I read the
first script the first episode after the
pilot and my shirt was off in a very
first scene so like okay okay I can do
that I read the second script the second
episode my shirt was off again I was
like okay then when I read the fourth
episode I was like okay my shirt was off
again I said I have to do something
because I need to be able to eat some
doughnuts some hamburgers you know guess
you want to work you're a doctor and
there are scenes where you're like
operating and you have no shirt on
we're at an ATM and you're shirtless it
needs to at least relate to the plot
okay
exactly exactly uh no I um I've been
offered any kind of acting gig which
hardly ever happens but they always say
Conan wearing as much clothing as
possible well you know what let's do
this I offer you an acting gig on our
show you can wear as less as you like
what do you mean come on our show I
would come on your show you can be
shirtless I want to be shirtless what I
would want is I would want the makeup
artists that actually give you the
six-pack they spray it on your body
people that can give you incredible
muscle tone will make that happen for
you okay
I actually know the guy I use him in my
personal life my wife's taking me to
dinner tonight
and we'd make up hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please